point final pour air lib et ses 3200
salariés le tribunal vient de prononcer
la liquidation judiciaire le repêchage
de dernière minute n'aura pas eu lieu
l'europe trouvera à thala consensus sur
la question irakienne la diplomatie
s'active à bruxelles tandis que
washington poursuit le déploiement de
ces unités dans la zone de guerre
invité le ministre belge des affaires
étrangères louis michel
deux gardiens de prison soupçonnés de
viol aux baumettes à marseille question
sur la présence d'un encadrement
masculin parmi des détenus femmes lutter
contre l'immigration clandestine un
projet de loi prévoit notamment de
renforcer les contrôles pour l'obtention
d'un certificat d'hébergement
enfin nous entrerons dans le monde des
insectes avec l'un des plus grands
centres de recherche installé à tour
rencontre avec des hommes qui
connaissent tous des termites et des
chenilles bonsoir à tous merci d'être
avec nous c'était une mort annoncée mais
la nouvelle il y à quelques instants a
été comme un électrochoc pour les
salariés d'air lib massés devant le
tribunal de commerce de créteil
la justice a donc prononcé la
liquidation judiciaire du deuxième pôle
aérien français céline crespy mathieu
dreujou
il y à quelques minutes la nouvelle est
tombée comme un couperet la liquidation
d'air lib est officiel
et pourtant on bien salsa cet après midi
les salariés der liebe croyait au
tribunal de commerce de créteil se
jouaient leur sort liquidation ou
redressement judiciaire c'est à dire la
possibilité de voir un repreneur
s'annonce et nous sortent du trou là
tout le matériel pour exploiter la
compagnie faut en sortir du trou il ya
un désir depuis nous voir exister chez
l'imposition c'est ce que je ressens
la direction lui fait confiance
je sais plus je sais bien
d'autant que les syndicats s'interrogent
sur le patrimoine des filiales
étrangères d'air libre et celui de la
maison mère ou le court propriété à 100%
du pdg jean-charles corbet car la
faillite d'air lib ne signifie pas
forcément celle de la maison mère via
une holding qui chapeaute l'ensemble et
qu'en fait pour l'instant il n'ya kehrli
qui est mis en dépôt de bilan et pas
l'ensemble des filiales donc un moment
donné c'est vrai qu'on a très peur que
quelque part le le le le devenir d un
livre devienne autonome et dramatique
dans d'un côté et puis que l'ensemble
des filiales ne soit pas touchée par le
désastre
après six longues heures d'attentes pour
les salariés à 15 heures les
représentants du comité d'entreprise
sortent enfin du tribunal de mauvaises
nouvelles en poche le procureur de la
république qui est le dernier à prendre
la parole et on peut pas répliquer après
a rejeté toute possibilité de
redressement
pourtant deux repreneurs en plus du
néerlandais unca aux réalités sur les
rangs ce qui n'aura pas suffi pour
sauver les 3200 salariés d'air lib
quel avenir maintenant pour les 3200
salariés d'air lib le compte à rebours a
commencé des contacts ont d'ores et déjà
été pris pour tenter de reclasser le
personnel dans les entreprises publiques
comme air france la ratp ou la sncf sans
grand espoir pour les salariés martin
gouès jean-paul chaussée depuis dix
jours l'inquiétude des salariés d'air
lib ne faisait qu'augmenter la fin de
cette compagnie aérienne et le plan
social le plus important depuis moulinex
en octobre 2001 les salariés n'imagine
pas un reclassement dans d'autres
entreprises
et pour moi c'est très difficile on est
tous les deux dans la même entreprise et
sera difficile pour tous les deux être
tous les deux au chômage avec savéol
pour le moment on est incapable de
l'envisager airs libre ce sont 380 5
pilotes et mécaniciens 993 hôtesses et
stewards et 1347 personne au sol air
france la sncf la ratp se sont engagé à
reclasser les licenciés de la compagnie
les syndicats n'y crois pas vous savez
on a des métiers très spécialisés
pilotes hôtesses de c'est de l'air
agents au sol c'est des métiers très
qualifiés très pointu est bon
aujourd'hui je pense pas que ces
entreprises et les mesures et les moyens
de nous offrir des postes
pour 3200 personnes des embauches qui se
ferait sous l'impulsion de l'actionnaire
principal de ces entreprises publiques
l'état
ça sera pas comme ça ça se fera par un
effort long un effort d'abord des
salariés eux mêmes je crois qu'ils
comprennent et puis par un effort des
entreprises pour leur faire des
propositions en 2001 air france avait
accueilli 669 ancien d'air libre
seulement 5 été reclassé à la ratp
aéroports de paris estime pouvoir
embaucher cette année une trentaine de
licenciés alors avec nous en direct de
créteil véronique saunier bonsoir vous
étiez chef de bonsoir en cours courrier
ar libre la fin d'un livre c'est un
drame pour vous d'autant que votre époux
est également salariés de la compagnie
oui tout à fait là on vient d'apprendre
la nouvelle il ya un peu près 20 minutes
et on le vit est vraiment comme un drame
c'est un gros choc effectivement il ya
certaines familles qui ont leur conjoint
dans la compagnie air libre en étant
vraiment objective c'est vrai que je
m'attendais à cette liquidation même
s'il y avait un espoir et aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment une grosse détresse
morale une grosse détresse physique
psychologique et maintenant évidemment
une grosse détresse financière qui nous
un comme on ne sait pas du tout au
niveau des dés
des du licenciement comment ça va se
passer nous n'avons qu'une information
j'ai juste appris qu'au niveau des ag as
les ag s était déficitaire et très
franchement là ce soir autour du
tribunal de commerce se sont bien sûr
comme vous pouvez vous en douter des
larmes des pleurs c'est dur moi je suis
rentré dans cette compagnie en 1990 on
avait un avion une destination sont la
réunion j'ai participé à l'essor de
cette compagnie avec tous mes collègues
étaient tous un maillon de la chaîne
et aujourd'hui malgré tout le potentiel
qui est autour de nous et bien tout
s'écroule et il va falloir rebondir mais
je le vis vraiment aujourd'hui comme un
deuil et je pèse mes mots en disant que
c'est un deuil j'enterre c'est comme si
je tairai quelqu'un de ma famille tout à
fait l'air franchement de la paix non
merci on l'aura compris merci pour ce
témoignage
et c'est dans ce contexte difficile pour
les salariés d'air libre que les pilotes
d'air france ont entamé ce matin une
grève de quatre jours grève peu suivie
puisque 90% des vols étaient assurés et
la totalité des passagers acheminés les
syndicats de pilotes réclament une
revalorisation de leurs salaires
la diplomatie européenne est à nouveau à
pied d'oeuvre depuis un peu plus d'une
heure les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement des quinze sont réunis à
bruxelles pour trouver une issue à la
crise européenne sur l'irak
la mobilisation ce week-end de 10
millions d'opposants à la guerre
en tout cas renforcé le camp de ceux qui
défendent l'option pacifique et la
poursuite des inspections jacques chirac
qui vient d'ailleurs de déclarer qu'ils
s'opposaient en l'état actuel des choses
à une nouvelle résolution du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu sur l'irak
nous l'écoutons nous sommes engagés dans
le cadre de la résolution 14h41 sur la
voie d'un désarmement par le biais des
inspecteurs
seul donc peuvent arrêter ce processus
et nous considérons tous imaginent que
la guerre est toujours toujours la pire
des solutions
voilà notre position qui nous conduisent
à en conclure qu'il n'est pas nécessaire
aujourd'hui d'avoir une deuxième
résolution à laquelle la france ne
pourrait que s'opposer cette position
jacques chirac la défendra ce soir lors
de la réunion qui se déroule
actuellement à bruxelles
il n'est pas exclu que les quinze
s'accordent sur un fragile consensus
pour afficher une cohésion de façade
bernard lebrun européen convaincu
voici l'homme qui a pris l'initiative de
ce redoutable sommet costas simitis
premier ministre grec actuel président
en exercice de l'union européenne
toujours en quête d'une difficile
position commune c'est vers lui avant la
réunion que le président chirac et
dominique de villepin sont allés pour
expliciter les arguments de la france
des débats qui dans cette salle
promettent d'être très animés car le 30
janvier dernier en publiant dans ce
journal anglais une lettre de soutien
washington l'europe afficher ses
divisions huit états n'ont signé la
grande bretagne l'espagne le portugal
l'italie et le danemark pour l'union
suivi de la pologne la tchéquie et la
hongrie
chez les futurs membres mais les
imposant défilé pour la paix du week-end
ont quelque peu changé la donne tout
particulièrement à londres rome et
madrid
difficile pour un gouvernement de partir
en guerre sans le soutien de son opinion
la division de l'union européenne sa
fille jusqu'au sein du conseil de
sécurité est pour l'instant parmi les 15
8 se sont exprimés affichant leurs
divergences
là où d'autres souligne avec
enthousiasme leurs convergences
permettez-moi seulement de dire à quel
point je suis heureux aujourd'hui
f ici en belgique dans un pays courageux
dès hier tony blair a confirmé qu'il
sera lié au calendrier amérique plus
d'inspections d'accord mais seulement
jusqu'au 28 février
la présence exceptionnelle à ce sommet
du secrétaire général des nations unies
kofi annan permettra peut-être de
pacifier les débats avec nous louis
michel ministre des affaires étrangères
de la belgique bonsoir le temps de notre
interview vous êtes sortis de la réunion
des 15 alors que se dit il à cette
réunion des quinze quel est le ton il se
dit de bonnes choses
il ya un échange de vues ont fait un
premier tour de table et nous avons
entendu un exposé fort intéressant du
secrétaire général de l'onu kofi annan
et donc on en est seulement aux
préliminaires pour l'instant est-ce
qu'on s'oriente vers un consensus
je pense qu'il est trop tôt pour le dire
mais j'ai pour ce qui me concerne la
conviction qu'après l'accord intervenu à
l'otan hier il y a les bases suffisantes
pour ouvrir la voie à un consensus je
pense qu'on peut certainement faire se
rejoindre disons les préoccupations ou
les priorités des uns et des autres
alors revenons sans justement à l'otan
vous l'avez cité qui est finalement
parvenu à un accord hier soir en
autorisant des mesures pour protéger la
turquie en cas de guerre en irak pendant
des semaines vous même vous êtes opposés
à ce compromis
hier soir vous avez levé vos réserves
est ce que ce n'est pas tout simplement
entrer dans une logique de guerre est
plié devant les états unis
je pense que lire soir tous les
observateurs un peu informé auront
constaté que la belgique avait ramené
les 17 pays beaucoup plus sur sa ligne
puisque les trois conditions que nous
avions voulu et les trois-quarts antique
nous voulions c'est à dire un lien
direct entre l'otan et les nations unies
il le fait que cette opération devait
strictement être une opération de
défense et de protection de la turquie
il ne pouvait en aucune manière être
interprété comme une intervention
militaire et le fait que
fallait nécessairement encore donner une
chance aux inspecteurs et donc à des
conditions avait à des procédures des
processus pacifique tout ça se trouve
dans le document qui a été admis hier
mais monsieur le ministre quand on dit
qu'on est prêt à protéger la turquie en
cas de guerre avec l'irak est ce qu'on
n'est pas en train de sous-entendre que
potentiellement on acquiesce une guerre
c'est génial madame que nous avons
décidé d'une planification nous n'avons
pas encore décidé de l'exécution de la
planification l'exécution de la
planification viendra est le suivant la
voie normale donc nous ne sommes pas
encore dans une logique de guerre et le
fait de protéger un pays à toutes fins
n'est pas encore à quoi être considérée
comme une logique de guerre ça va de soi
et l'article l'article 4 permet à la
turquie de demande et donc nous du
moment qu' il n'y avait pas cette
logique de guerre du moment qu'on
n'était pas entrer ou non ne s'oriente
pas vers une opération militaire
ils n'avaient évidemment aucune raison
de s'y opposer mais en échange de ce
vote tenu ainsi temps c'est dans cette
décision des éléments fondamentaux des
garanties fondamentales qui d'ailleurs
resto dans une certaine mesure la
mission fondamentale de l'otan merci
alors que la diplomatie européenne tente
de trouver un consensus à bruxelles
washington continue à déployer ses
troupes notamment turquie un
gouvernement turc y accepterait d'être
une base militaire américaine en cas de
conflit avec en échange l'espoir d'une
aide économique cher en bonis il cache
bien sa fatigue
lord robertson hier soir après une
semaine de crise à l'otan le secrétaire
général de l'organisation a obtenu à
l'arraché un accord sur la protection de
la turquie en cas de guerre en irak
ce n'est qu'une demi victoire car
l'accord a été trouvé dans une instance
où la france ne siège pas
cet accord prévoit l'envoi en turquie
d'un dispositif de défense des avions
radar awacs des missiles antimissile
patriot et des équipements anti
chimiques
un dispositif de protection mais pour
l'instant le premier ministre turc
abdullah gül n'a pas accepté que son
pays serve de base arrière à une
offensive
il exige des contreparties financières
donc en turquie des soldats américains
sont déjà au travail
quelques 4000 hommes du génie et
techniciens qui prépare l'arrivée du
gros de la troupe dans quatre aéroports
et de porcs la dynamique guerrière est
en marche
le pentagone prépare la mise en place
d'un deuxième front au nord à partir de
la turquie pour compléter le front sud
et prendre l'irak en tenaille
il semble même que les renseignements
américains soit à pied d'oeuvre sur la
frontière entre la turquie et l'irak
la chaîne cnn a diffusé ces images d'un
convoi de forces spéciales en route vers
le kurdistan irakien
à gaza le hamas a appelé tous ses
militants à être prêts à venger la mort
de six responsables de l'organisation
islamiste
il aurait été tué ce matin par l'armée
israélienne ne correspondant charles
enderlin et talal abou rahmeh ont
réalisé pour la première fois
l'interview du chef militaire du hamas à
nouveau gaza enterre ses morts
six responsables de la branche militaire
du hamas
le commando azzedine el kassam ils ont
été tués hier alors qu'ils manipulaient
un petit avion télécommandé bourré
d'explosifs qui projetait de lancer
contre un objectif israélien les
islamistes attribue cette explosion à
israël il foule énorme participent à
leurs obsèques
surtout cet homme masqué mohamed des le
chef militaire du hamas
à plusieurs reprises sarah l'attenté de
le liquider
la dernière fois en septembre 2002
gravement blessé il avait échappé à la
mort
c'est l'ennemi public numéro un
distraire nous les combattants d'al
qassam dit-il nous affirmons qu'il n'y
aura pas de négociations avec israël ou
avec l'amérique
nous disons à tous les négociateurs il
n'y aura pas de concessions
en d'autres termes c'est la fin des
efforts de l'egypte et de l'union
européenne
pour parvenir à un cessez-le-feu l'armée
israélienne a accentué son offensive
contre le hamas
durant la matinée une unité spéciale
avec un autre chef de l'organisation
dans le centre de la bande de gaza ce
n'est pas tout les brigades al aqsa
proches du fatah de yasser arafat le
djihad islamique promettent de durcir le
combat
les deux mouvements coopèrent ses
militants présentent le butin ramassé
lors de la destruction d'un char
israëlien avant-hier
quatre soldats ont été tués un cycle de
morts que rien ne semble pouvoir arrêter
enfants c'est une affaire embarrassante
pour l'administration pénitentiaire de
surveillants de la maison d'arrêt des
baumettes à marseille ont été mises en
examen pour le viol d'une détenue des
agissements qui pose la question de la
présence de personnel masculin pour
encadrer les femmes incarcérées
laurent dit benoît autres cinq viols
aggravés et une agression sexuelle
contre deux des tenues féminines
l'accusation qui pèse sur deux
surveillants des baumettes est très
grave
elle surprend énormément les
organisations syndicales ça me paraît
inconcevable dans la mesure où l
architecture ne permet pas justement de
ce ce type de 2 enfin ce genre de chose
qui est reproché d'en cas nos collègues
et dans le fonctionnement lui-même je
veux dire les surveillants en détention
femmes n'ont pas accès aux cellules
comme ça car normalement seuls les
surveillantes féminines sont habilités à
intervenir en contact direct avec les
femmes détenues les hommes sont
également présents mais en principe
plutôt cantonné à des tâches de
surveillance générale si l'anc est
démontre effectivement qu'ils ont pu
avoir accès à cette détention femme
malgré l'organisation et malgré les
règles qui avaient été mises en place eh
bien nous en tirerons un certain nombre
de conséquences
pour l'heure les deux surveillants ont
été suspendus provisoirement mise en
examen et placé sous contrôle judiciaire
mais ils ont été laissés en liberté
le premier affecté au contrôle des accès
nie toute implication
le second reconnaît des rapports sexuels
mais d'après lui avec le consentement de
la détenue les détenus sont dans une
situation de dépendance totale de
l'administration pénitentiaire et des
gens qui les sert c'est à dire des
surveillants donc il n'est pas possible
de pouvoir considérer qu'il puisse y
avoir un consentement quelconque
l'enquète devra enfin déterminer si
d'autres jeunes femmes détenues on tue à
subir des agissements similaires
pour l'instant aucune autre plainte n'a
été déposée le calvaire de sarah n'en
finit pas cette adolescente de roubaix
avait été victime d'un viol collectif
elle avait osé rompre la loi du silence
en dénonçant ses agresseurs mais depuis
la peur des représailles l'a obligé à
déménager deux fois fanni au vernis
depuis quelques jours le père de sarah
n'ose plus sortir de chez lui
le cauchemar continue la semaine
dernière trois des neuf agresseur
présumé de sa fille sont sortis de
prison avant leur procès les adolescents
sont accusés de viol collectif sur sarah
13 ans c'est à dire que moins d'après ce
que je comprends c'est qu'on prend plus
de considération les agresseurs que les
victimes puisque maintenant ils sont
relâchés que nous on va rigoler de nous
depuis que sarah a porté plainte
sa famille a dû déménager mais les
proches des agresseurs les ont retrouvés
menaces injures
la situation est devenue intenable
sarrail ses parents veulent changer de
logement à nouveau au plus vite
personne ne veut de ce qui est
particulièrement scandaleux parce que je
pense que sur un point de solidarité
nationale le moins qu'on pourrait faire
pour cette famille c'est de les prendre
en charge je pense quand même que cette
jeune fille a été victime d'actes
répréhensibles très graves et que la
famille a le droit d'être aidé le mois
dernier sarah dû quitter son collège à
la demande du principal il ne
garantissait plus sa sécurité
on est toujours sans nouvelles des
jumelles quinquagénaire mystérieusement
disparu depuis jeudi dans les alpes
maritimes les gendarmes n'excluent
aucune hypothèse
véronique jean collette et stella kluger
ont fait leurs courses à la boulangerie
de la bolline valdeblore jeudi dernier
comme si elles préparaient leur déjeuner
depuis leur départ de ce commerce plus
aucune nouvelle des deux soeurs jumelles
et jean-louis cinq enfants âgés de 55
ans et originaire du var les deux soeurs
étaient venus dans les alpes-maritimes
se reposer chez des proches
colette venait de perdre son compagnon
elle avait demandé à sa soeur de la
compagnie c'était là souffre de
paralysie à la suite d'une hémiplégie
et elle est très influencé par sa soeur
colette qui elle est connue pour avoir
les tendances dépressives suite à une
dépression il ya vingt ans elle avait
pris était parti comme ça du jour au
lendemain pour rejoindre sa soeur et
laquelle elle est très lié sa survie
mais sur paris et en fin de compte on
l'avait retrouvé sur un quai de gare à
lyon pour l'heure les enquêteurs n'ont
trouvé aucun indice sur le terrain
aujourd'hui des vérifications sont
menées au niveau des comptes bancaires
des jumelles kruger demain les
recherches reprendront à 0 depuis la
boulangerie du village
on peut aller en plusieurs hypothèses ou
à chercher d'où un enlèvement qui est
crapuleux
une fugue finale ce qui n'est pas
impossible puisque à priori cette dame
de genté parti d'une vingtaine d'années
un avis de recherche national a été
lancé pour retrouver colette et stella
kluger 50 hommes et un hélicoptère
seront mobilisés demain pour faire
avancer l'enquêté
la lutte contre l'immigration
clandestine nicolas sarkozy en a fait
son cheval de bataille son cabinet
prépare un projet de loi qui durcit les
conditions d'accès et de séjour des
étrangers
voici point par point
qui devrait être proposé au parlement
avant l'été mathias hillion michel
levasseur pour lutter contre
l'immigration clandestine
nicolas sarkozy a beaucoup d'idées ça
fait trop longtemps que sur
l'immigration les anathèmes ont pris la
place du raisonnement il faut avoir un
raisonnement la matière en visite au
mali il avait mis l'accent sur l'aide au
retour
ce matin le figaro révélait un avant
projet de loi du ministre de l'intérieur
mesure principale l'allongement de la
durée de rétention des clandestins sous
le coup d'un arrêté de reconduite à la
frontière
elle pourrait passer de 12 à 60 jours
les associations des deux étrangers
dénonce qu'une proposition attentatoires
aux libertés individuelles est il
efficace priver les gens de liberté au
fait qu'ils n'ont pas de papiers ne
permet pas forcément de l'efficacité la
reconduite puisque celle ci est liée à
trouver un pays de destination et quand
des gens sont en situation d'être
bloquées et enfermé bas ils sont bloqués
et enfermé ça change rien
autre mesure envisagée la création d'un
fichier pour mieux contrôler les
attestations d'accueil
anciennement appelée certificat
d'hébergement elles sont obligatoires
pour accueillir chez soi un étranger
les syndicats de magistrats ont appris
ces propositions dans le journal on
livre des projets de loi en quelque
sorte clé en main quitte à revenir sur
certaines dispositions après sans jamais
consulter ni les avocats ni les
magistrats ni les jurys pour le
ministère de l'intérieur
ces propositions ne sont qu'un document
de travail l'objectif
envoyer davantage de clandestins dans
leur pays d'origine
aujourd'hui seule une mesure de
reconduite à la frontière sur cinq est
effective
le projet prévoit de renforcer ce que
l'on appelle les certificats
d'hébergement en clair ce sont des
attestation d'accueil qui doivent être
signé par les maires mais voilà les élus
n'ont pas les moyens de contrôler la
véracité des demandes
le texte prévoit de les aider à faire le
tri entre les dossiers valérie fournis
ou dorothée cochard alain poirier un
billet d'entrée pour la france depuis
il suffit à l'hébergeur qui souhaitent
accueillir un étranger sur le sol
français de justifier de son identité de
son domicile pour obtenir une
attestation d'accueil comme ici on
irie ce document permet ensuite
d'obtenir un visa de séjour de trois
mois
la loi ne prévoit aucun réel contrôle et
lorsque les mères signe ces attestations
c'est sans réelle garantie que la
personne hébergée regagne bien son pays
d'origine
je pense que dans la plupart des cas les
gens repartent sont tenues pendant une
période en france mais on ne sait pas
très bien ce qui se passe après donc je
crois qu'on a intérêt à en savoir un peu
plus et à faire en sorte que ce soit
plus transparent et plus lisible pour
tout le monde pour l'état mais aussi
pour les maires par peur de
l'immigration clandestine ce maire lui
refuse de signer ces attestations et les
transmet au commissariat mais il en
conserve un double pour ses statistiques
personnelles donc majorité les pays du
maghreb l'afrique noire l'europe de
l'est
c'est vrai que je n'ai pas voulu être
complice d'un simulacre de contrôle par
choix que de mettre une signature sur
une attestation sur l'honneur
c'est vraiment
un coup d'épée dans l'eau pour ces deux
mères un meilleur contrôle s'impose
l'un comme l'autre sont aujourd'hui dans
l'incapacité de dire combien d'étrangers
venus sur leur commune sont réellement
reparti l'accident de car scolaire ce
matin à plouvara dans les côtes d'armor
aurait pu être beaucoup plus dramatique
heureusement seuls 19 enfants ont été
légèrement blessé le conducteur lui a
été plus grièvement atteints la
collision s'est produite entre le car et
une voiture
après la stupéfaction l'inquiétude et
les interrogations les riverains de
l'école maternelle de paris qui s'est
effondrée ce week-end redoutent d'autres
incidents il faut dire que l'école est
située au dessus de la ligne de métro
meteor le sous sol parisien ressemble
par endroits un gruyère nathalie sapina
sans marque mythique l'opposition 20e
étage difficile de s'habituer
trois jours après l'effondrement de la
cour de l'école auguste perret is you
reste fasciné par le trou béant au pied
de la tour
ma belle mère m'a dit que son lit a
sauté réellement il ya eu une onde de
choc extrêmement violente
même inquiétude chez johanna dont la
terrasse donne trois étages au dessus de
la cour de l'école et fonderies un grand
boum comme comme un avion éventuellement
qui fait ma paie au mcs troll je sais
pas la cause de cet effondrement
le chantier de la ligne de métro meteor
qui depuis un an et demi faisait vibrer
tout le quartier
dans l'école même les institutrices
avait remarqué quelques signaux
inquiétants dans des murs tremblaient et
il ya eu pas mal de fissures dans
l'école qui ont été constatées et
signalé et ben on craignait toujours qui
se passe quelque chose en fait
il ya eu aussi le sol de la cour qui est
un petit peu a cessé puisque pendant un
moment ne pouvait plus fermé la porte
d'entrée la porte verte derrière moi
donc ils sont venus rehausser la porte
pour qu'on puisse de nouveau la ferme et
donc il y avait quand même des
affaissements de terme
pour l'instant il est trop tôt pour dire
si ces dégradations étaient des signes
précurseurs
ce qu'on sait la cour était situé
au-dessus d'un tunnel particulièrement
large pas encore consolidée et qui
devait servir de garage pour la ratp le
reste du chantier ne présente pas de riz
les riverains ne sont pas en danger
le même ceux qui sont au dessus du
tunnel parce que la situation du tunnel
est extrêmement différente de la
situation dans laquelle il y a eu lieu
l'effondrement une enquête a été ouverte
pour déterminer les responsabilités
la ville de paris cet après midi a saisi
le tribunal administratif en référé de
manière à ce qu'un expert soit désigné
que la justice puisse être appelés à
dire quelles sont les causes de
l'accident de son point de vue
aujourd'hui l'urgence est de trouver des
locaux pour les 900 élèves du groupe
scolaire qui doivent reprendre les cours
dans une semaine
mauvais vent sur le port breton de
concarneau la justice enquête sur un
marché parallèle de vente de poissons en
fait les pêcheurs détourné des centaines
de tonnes de poissons du circuit
commercial pour améliorer leurs revenus
chaque de vote michel hiver lagoda et
c'est une tradition séculaire chaque
marin perçoit une partie de la pêche
quelques poissons
une vingtaine de kilos pour nourrir sa
famille mais en bretagne la pratique a
semble-t-il dérapé ainsi à concarneau
pour deux armements délais mais ni pts
la godaille s'élèverait à un million et
demi d'euros pour chacun sur la pêche
annuelle d'un bateau les frais de voyage
est acquitté si l'afer qui a disparu
non on ne peut pas accepter par
l'entreprise non ce qui empêche leur
investissement et on ne peut pas en
situation des pêches maritimes pour
mâles se plaint d'aucune bateaux sont
vendus que les emplois disparaissent et
soi même contribuer à un projet
à la profession d'avenir pour les
syndicats de marins les volumes atteint
près de 200 tonnes de poissons sont
aberrants mais pour autant refusent de
voir les marins cloué au pilori selon
les syndicats au fil du temps la
godaille est devenu une variable
d'ajustement bien utile quand la pêche
n'est pas bonne pour pouvoir garder des
équipages en cas de crise ou en cas de
salaires trop bas
les armateurs aurait mis les dépenses
mais les dépassements assurer des
salaires corrects
une fois que ça a été admis une fois
deux fois trois fois et pendant des des
années voire 20 ans maintenant il est
très difficile de faire marche arrière
la responsabilité elle est réparé sa g
le mareyeur qui a écoulé la godaille n'a
pas souhaité s'exprimer
mais il réfute tout trafic le poisson a
été acheté aux marins dans la plus
grande transparence et l'achat de go die
c'est toujours pratiqué dans la
profession ses confrères en tout cas ne
sont pas mécontents de voir cesser une
concurrence jugée déloyale
certains toulouse l'appelle déjà
l'airbus ville la construction de l'a380
à blagnac est un gigantesque chantier
qui va dynamiser toute l'économie locale
l'installation de l' usine d'assemblage
est à elle seule une prouesse technique
isabelle de lyon david presse voici en
accéléré le record du jour une charpente
métallique de 8500 tonnes en acier plus
lourde que la tour eiffel qui monte à 46
mètres de haut
l'exploit est à mettre à l'actif
d'airbus qui construit la l'usiné
d'assemblage de son futur gros porteur
l'a380
les travaux avancent à grands pas dans
une zone industrielle appelé
aéroconstellation mais que l'on surnomme
déjà airbus vide
l'avion de passagers le plus grand du
monde va drainer ici un volume d'emplois
considérable surtout c'est la
conjoncture reste porteuse pendant un
certain nombre d'années
ce seront des emplois nouveaux on estime
que l'ensemble des emplois sur la région
directs et induits sont de l'ordre de
dix mille emplois
d'autres entreprises sont attendus tout
lié au secteur aéronautique
comme air france qui élève de terre
son centre de maintenance si nous allons
là ce n'est pas hasard c'est que nous
mettons avec airbus des moyens en commun
l'ensemble des taxiways le mot synergie
veut dire effectivement économies pour
nous en face de lusine 200 hectares de
champs dans dix ans on nous promet ici
des bureaux des immeubles des écoles des
commerces de cette zone on aura quelque
chose comme 4000 à 5000 habitants alors
en argent investi publiquement ça
représente à peu près je dirais 100
millions d'euros en termes
d'investissements de la puissance
publique
mais je ne sais pas encore exactement
dire ce que ça va représenter si j'y
rajoute ce que tous les privés vont
réinvestir six petites communes sont
riches iront des taxes foncières le
grand toulouse de la taxe
professionnelle
aujourd'hui on politiques locaux
industriels posé devant l'usiné
comme on le dit en terre d'ovalie tout
le monde a poussé dans le même sens
séance plutôt inhabituel aujourd'hui
devant les prud'hommes de pau c'est un
homme de 83 ans qui est venue demander
des dommages et intérêts à l'état
allemand
pendant deux ans ils avaient été enrôlés
au sein du st lô le service de travail
obligatoire f bortoli alice bouilhaguet
josé boulesteix albert n'a jamais pu
oublier
il se déplace aujourd'hui difficilement
mais il a tenu à venir raconter son
histoire devant les prud'hommes 1943
comme 650 mille jeunes français il part
pour le st home le service du travail
obligatoire pendant deux ans il
travaille de force en allemagne sans
savoir il produit du zyklon b le gaz
utilisé à six kilomètres de là à
auschwitz tu peux parler de cette époque
non aujourd'hui albert ne peut plus
s'exprimer
sa femme a repris son combat à elle
d'obtenir une reconnaissance de tout ce
qu'il a subi
je voudrais
plon supprime radicalement le terme
service du travail obligatoire et de
donner le titre de déportés faute de
s'entendre sur les mots il lui reste la
possibilité de se battre pour être
indemnisé une loi allemande reconnaît au
st lô le statut de travailleurs forcés
nous dresse et ne travailler 15 heures
par roulement jour et nuit et se
teintera veille
l'allemagne elle estime avoir déjà payé
en 1961 plus de 200 millions d'euros ont
été versés aux français ayant fait
l'objet de persécutions
parmi eux aucun st lô si l'allemagne
refuse de payer son avocat se retournera
alors contre l'état français
s'il n'y avait pas eu de lois françaises
ces gens là ne serait jamais parti par
conséquent la france est tout aussi
responsable de ce travail forcé que
l'allemagne
le délibéré sera rendu le 31 mars mais à
chaque fois que l'allemagne est
condamnée elle a fait appel à 83 ans
albert risque de devoir encore patienter
près de 8 euros par jour depuis ce matin
londres est devenue l'une des rares
capitales à péage impossible de fraude
et 800 caméras veille alors les
londoniens ce matin ont mis la main au
portefeuille ont dû trouver un autre
moyen de locomotion
arnauld miguet dominique marault tél
un véritable paradis pour les cyclistes
cet après-midi le trafic était
inhabituellement fluide
certaines rues du centre de londres
quasiment déserte même les
automobilistes qui avaient pourtant
payer la fameuse taxe d'embouteillage
étaient ravis attendez si ça reste comme
ça c'est génial ça rend la vie plus
facile
il y a moins d'embouteillages c'est plus
rapide pour venir dans londres j'ai
gagné 20 minutes ce matin le plus
satisfait de tout c'est lui
ken livingstone le maire de londres
contre vents et marées il avait fait de
cette taxe son cheval de bataille
si ça marche le monde entier ne copiera
aller à vélo c'est gratuit mais le ph
est loin de faire l'unanimité
certains qui devraient être supprimés
c'est un impôt supplémentaire
l'heure n'est pas encore au bilan au
soir du premier jour pour avoir échappé
à cette babel des temps modernes
certains regrettent déjà l'inconfort du
métro d'autres pensent sérieusement à
investir dans la moto la petite auto
électrique exempte de taxes se fait
encore rare enfin certains sont prêts à
se jeter à l'eau
m
après washington et philadelphie s'est
finalement new york qui est paralysé par
une tempête de neige des intempéries du
rare intensité comme a pu le constater
notre correspondant etienne leenhardt la
pelleteuse à moteur c'était ce matin
l'engin le plus recherché de la capitale
américaine où les rues d'ordinaire
complètement congestionnée ressembler
beaucoup plus à des pistes de ski de
fond
j'aurais bien aimé dit cet homme que les
4,4 nous laisse tranquille quelques
jours 70 cm de poudreuse dans les
jardins de la maison blanche cela fait
sept ans qu'il n'avait pas autant neigé
l'activité politique fonctionner au
ralenti et les correspondants de la
chose présidentielle en était réduit à
interviewer les chiens de george bush la
tempête a gagné new york dans la matinée
beaucoup de commerces sont fermés ainsi
que les aéroports où de très nombreux
vols ont été annulés
si tout va bien ont prévenu les
autorités
les chutes de neige devraient cesser
dans la soirée mais il faudra
probablement au moins deux ou trois
jours avant que la situation ne revienne
tout à fait normal mais le calendrier
fait relativement bien les choses car
l'une des plus grosses tempêtes que la
côte est est connu depuis bien longtemps
survient un jour férié le jour du
président
plus anecdotique en france les hauteurs
de bastia sous la neige également une
alerte de niveau 3 est maintenue jusqu'à
demain en corse
et puis près de perpignan c'est une
tempête de neige qui a provoqué des
difficultés de circulation sur l'a 9
mais aucune mesure particulière de
restriction n'a été prise la france
vient de se doter d'un des plus grands
centres de recherche sur l'insecte il
est installé à tour alors n'imaginais
pas des professeurs nimbus enfermés dans
des laboratoires bien au contraire ces
hommes et ces femmes travaillent sur des
sujets bien concret notamment les
termites c'est aux sectes insidieux que
rien ne semble arrêter laetitia fuchs
sylvain doba leur plat favori
la cellulose le bois de nos forêts et de
nos mises en france on dénombre cinq
espèces de termites que l'on retrouve
partout en europe
les chercheurs de l'institut de
recherche de la biologie de l'insecte
sont les seuls à étudier cet insecte
sociale qui évolue en colonie comme la
fourrure avec le réchauffement
climatique
les termites remonte vers le nord et
font de nouveaux ravages
en fait ya beaucoup d'arbres qui sont
terminées à paris mais il les arbres
sont en fait sont termites et parce
qu'il ya des termites dans les bâtiments
ils sentent que les arabes sont un petit
peu fragile à paris et vienne
ils viennent d'attaquer les arbres fléau
de nos habitations le termite joue
néanmoins un rôle essentiel dans
l'écosystème en s'attaquant aux bois
mort ou malade il fabrique ainsi la
couche supérieure du sol tous les
insectes ont également une fonction la
décomposition la pollinisation
le fait d'être de la nourriture pour
d'autres organismes
le fait de pouvoir manger des algues des
plantes aussi dans les systèmes
aquatiques qui sont importants cette
chenille accros à la nicotine ravages
des chants anti de tabac et ne crache
pas sur les tomates et aubergines son
ennemi cette guêpe qui se sert de son
corps pour y pondre ses oeufs
ce faisant elle lui transmet un virus
mortel à terre est d'identifier les
molécules qui sont produites par ce
virus
c'est qu'en fait ces molécules peuvent
être utilisé comme insecticide naturel
en fait contre les insectes la nature au
service de l'agriculture
avec cette solution on éviterait bien
des pollutions football bordeaux
qualifié pour les quarts de finale de la
coupe de france les girondins ont battu
wasquehal 81 un doublé de pauleta et un
autre de darcheville les bordelais
rejoignait si trois autres clubs de
ligue 1 ce stade de la compétition c'est
à dire paris rennes et auxerre découvrir
le but voilà et on retrouve dans
quelques instants l'émission 100 minutes
pour comprendre que prendre cette guerre
qu'on nous annonce en irak
olivier mazerolle vous recevez raymond
barre bonsoir oui bonsoir raymond barre
et bien d'autres invités mais raymond
barre va nous apporter sa connaissance
de la scène internationale et l'économie
mondiale pour que nous voyons avec lui
quelles sont les conséquences possibles
de cette guerre toujours probable et
puis nous aurons beaucoup
d'interlocuteurs notamment à washington
richard pearl qui est l'un des plus
influents conseillers du président en
bouche
nous irons aussi à jérusalem à londres
pour voir si les européens savaient
qu'ils sont réunis en ce moment à
bruxelles demain nous irons à londres
avec un député britannique pour voir ces
européens peuvent retrouver le chemin de
l'unité ne seront également en ligne à
paris le directeur de la dst qui c'est
qui
apparaîtra pour la première fois la
télévision pour nous dire quels sont les
risques terroristes dont vous voyez
beaucoup de choses ce soir sur ce
plateau de france 2 pour essayer de
comprendre tous les enjeux de cette
guerre annoncée
merci olivier c'est la fin de ce journal
merci de l'avoir suivi tout de suite la
météo avec isabelle martinez 100 minutes
pour comprendre présenté par olivier
mazerolle 22h50 complément dans le cas
de benoît duquesne au sommaire la base
du tourisme aux antilles françaises
00h45 dernier journal laurence piquet
dès 6h30 télématin dans les 4 vérités
françoise laborde recevra emile shoufani
curé de nazareth en israël
et on se quitte sur ce pense-bête
n'oubliez pas qu'il ne vous reste plus
que quelques heures pour payer votre
premier tiers de l'impôt sur le revenu
vous avez jusqu'à minuit passé ce délai
vous serez majoré à demain bonsoir